the plan hasn't changed the consumers
haven't changed really its prohibition
hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer friesen TV and
today we're talking with Mark Jordan
he's an economics professor at Auburn
University he's also the author of
economics of prohibition and a senior
fellow at the Mises Institute mark
thanks for talking to us it's great to
be with you so recent studies have shown
that the potency of marijuana has
increased a lot with THC levels rising
from only half a percent in the 1970s to
twenty five percent today so do you
think these are correct allegations and
why do you think they've come about
marijuana the 1970s contained other
leaves and the seeds and everything so
it was a miss measurement and today when
you get look at the samples that are
twenty-five percent potent they're
basically just the flower of the plant
and there's no stems or seeds and things
you don't need and so there is a
measurement air in that but there's no
doubt that the potency of marijuana that
gets onto the streets of America today
is much higher and it continues to get
even higher and there's been speculation
about this ranging from theories of
market failure to supply side economics
and you say it's just because of
prohibition that's correct its
prohibition that's driving this market
place consumers don't necessarily need
or seek out these higher potency
products they're more expensive for one
thing but prohibition drives suppliers
the people who grow it the people who
transport it the people who sell it to
make it more compact and as a result
it's more potent when it reaches the
street so the plant hasn't changed the
consumers haven't changed really its
prohibition and the ever difficulties in
risks of getting it from the growing
stage to the consumer are people who are
saying there's twenty five percent
levels of THC are they just using this
as a scare tactic yes it's very much a
scare tactic issue the twenty-five
percent shows up in only a few samples
of marijuana which were created and
produced for medical marijuana
dispensaries for certain types of
medical problems and that's the kind of
thing we want by targeting the way that
marijuana has grown and the types of
strains that are used the marketplace is
going to produce targeted products that
are going to help specific people and
without necessarily making them
tremendously high and unable to work
could you make any parallels between
this and alcohol prohibition oh sure the
same thing happened during alcohol
prohibition you know Americans were beer
drinkers back in the 1920s and whiskey
was a minor part of the alcohol market
in beer was the dominant player in the
alcohol market during Prohibition 90
cents of every dollar was spent on
whiskey poor quality high potency
whiskey so there's no doubt and if you
look at an Auburn football game
typically what you'll find is tailgaters
a hundred thousand tailgaters and most
of them are drinking beer but once they
go into the stadium what kind of alcohol
do they drink they bring in a flask of
whiskey because it's prohibited it's a
phenomenon that exists any time
government tries to prevent the
consumption of something and bring that
to other illegal drugs i mean have
potency levels of heroin or cocaine gone
up well you know the potency of
marijuana rising isn't really a
tremendous problem because it's not a
lethal drug you don't overdose on it but
the same thing applies to cocaine heroin
and all these other drugs the dealers in
those markets also want to concentrate
their product as much as possible and so
as a result at least in the distribution
level heroin cocaine crystal meth are
very highly potent products in and then
every time the government puts the
squeeze on the market suppliers look for
even more dangerous drugs if I'm being
optimistic grant during an era of
legalization you think the market will
correct itself and return to less potent
levels well I think that under an era of
legalized marijuana what you'll find is
a a more mild marijuana product that is
not highly concentrated I think the
consumers and consumer choice will
ultimately bring about a variety of
products products that are not extremely
highly poke
and products for which the customer
knows more about the potency and the
chemical composition of what they're
consuming so the market will bring about
more information more safety more choice
do you think that's enough or do you
think you know the FDA might still get
involved I hope not the FDA and whenever
they put their hands on something
ultimately it's bad for the American
consumer drugs food the FDA seal of
approval creates moral hazards that says
this drug is okay so doctors prescribe
it too often consumers consume it too
often and so the FDA needs to set stay
hands off of this issue well mark thank
you so much for talking to us well you
certainly hit all the high points no pun
intended friesen TV I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer